salut et merci de votre fidélité à ce
rendez vous on part à la rencontre des
martiniquais qui vivent à l'étranger
aujourd'hui direction le canada ont
parlé retrouver ingrid labo une
martiniquaise qui a l'habitude des
voyages mais qui s'est installée il ya
un peu plus d'un an à montréal
elle vit et il travaille pour le comité
martiniquais du tourisme
[Musique]
salut ingrid on est au canada c'est ça
exactement est amené à montréal
quel temps il fait à montréal en tout
sont gérables c'est que le canada cette
période de l'année fait quand même
encore un petit peu froid non bah écoute
les températures remontent doucement
mais sûrement c'est vrai que la semaine
dernière il a quand même neigé n'avons
qu'un mois de mai mais dans la salle
léon peu parce que ça commence à sera
dossier pour vous en deux tours du
courant d'un virus au canada la
situation et n'était pas comme en france
en fait nous n'étions pas confiné
obligatoirement s'était vivement
conseillée pour le moment le la
situation ne se stabilise pas beaucoup
malheureusement que le confinement
vivement conseillée est donc repoussé la
fin du contrat est donc repoussée à la
fin du mois je sais qu'en france et des
attestations saga mais des attestations
a signé justifier de son déplacement on
n'a jamais vécu ça ici mais c'est la
population canadienne est quand même
assez respectueuse de tous qui est
distanciation social ici c'est de mettre
le port du masque et et généralisée
voilà une chanson plutôt attention ils
ont un vrai savoir alors qu'ils
travaillent à montréal pour le comité
martiniquais du tourisme
j'imagine qu'en matière de tourisme vous
poser beaucoup de questions pour
l'avenir pourtant plus tard et surtout
pour nous pour la martinique comment ça
va se passer après
exactement c'est à dire que les missions
du cnt ont été redirigés vers
l'accompagnement des socioprofessionnels
en martinique
et puis voilà réfléchir à des stratégies
de relance les accompagner pour qu'ils
puissent eux aussi de traverser cette
crise
la meilleure façon possible si je
cuisine puis bien sûr qu'il puisse se
relancer derrière donc on a entendu que
le territoire française s'ouvre au moins
au d'octobre et les on se reprend ce qui
n'est pas encore le cas pour les voiles
internationaux donc pour mémoire ils
s'étaient quand on est tous on est comme
tout le monde en fait on est en attente
de l'évolution de
des décisions relatives à l'évolution de
l'épidémie tu as l'habitude de voyager
avant montréal avant de partir au canada
tu as fait plusieurs pays devant un
grand repris pendant par un petit peu de
temps même je crois c'est en fait j'ai
fait mon stage de fin d'études en inde
ensuite voilà j'ai travaillé après avoir
quitté l'inde j'ai pu faire une sorte de
road trip backpacker en asie du sud est
dans tout ce qui est vietnam laos
cambodge thaïlande pour finalement
atterrir en australie
ça date d'il ya presque dix ans
maintenant
donc j'ai travaillé en australie j'ai
visité aussi la nouvelle zélande qui est
un pays magnifique et puis après l'appel
du cailly je suis retourné en martinique
et puis avec la marque et qu'on m'a
proposé cette belle opportunité sur le
canada est comme entre temps j'ai eu à
l'enfant de la fin quand aujourd'hui le
canada s'agirait surtout montréal une
ville où notre très intéressante en fait
pour les familles qui est plutôt
sécuritaire aussi c'est très cosmopolite
et jenson d'un esprit donc c'est
intéressant ce mélange de cultures
l'anglais le français
on voit des choses justement on a
beaucoup de martiniquais qui partent
s'installer à montréal on a eu
d'ailleurs l'occasion d'avoir dj tracks
il ya quelques semaines qui et beatmaker
et ingénieur du son qui vit là bas et
qui me disait qu'il y avait une petite
communauté qui était quand même présenté
kittila de martiniquais et c'est vrai
que le sentiment qu'on en a par rapport
au retour qu'on a sur montréal et le
canada en général c'est que c'est un
lieu très agréable à vivre et où si on
respecte les cultures des autres où la
culture de l'autre c'est on considère
que c'est aussi un apport qui enrichit
le pays qui enrichit montréal exactement
c'est à dire que effectivement la
communauté des états c est assez
présente surtout estudiantine
il y en a de plus en plus viennent et
puis ya des échanges des partenariats
qui se font avec les unités
et c'est vrai que montréal pour le co
est temps que les canadiens sont assez
respectueux des différences de chacun il
ya des quartiers où il ya plus de
communiquer tous deux communautés que
d'autres mais malgré ça tout le monde
arrive à avoir un grand savoir vivre ça
va être un échange et même des quartiers
où il ya que des juifs orthodoxes et
tout se passait très bien effectivement
pour après mais globalement ça va parce
que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
agréable
malgré cette situation cieux gêne malgré
tout ça on a réussi vraiment chose que
le bis est vraiment bien organisée
autour de ça et c'est pas trop
contraignant finale au quotidien on
entrevoit bientôt en martinique et après
tout ça ce qui me manque beaucoup parce
que quand tu rencontres un canadien dans
le cadre justement de ton travail nous
cmt s'il fallait que tu lui parles en
une phrase de la martinique tu dirais
quoi qu'est la partie n'est que c'est un
mélange de saveurs culinaires mais non
ceux d'afrique et d'asie
surtout d'inde avec sa mort c'est la
française est tué et quatre frenchies
touch très séduisante merci beaucoup
pour cet petit moment avec toi je sais
ta rendez vous juste après pour le
travail on pas trop tenir plus longtemps
c'était quand même un plaisir d'échanger
avec toi ingrid on espère te voir très
vite en martinique on espère aussi
surtout que très bientôt on pourra
accueillir les canadiens dans de bonnes
conditions
on a besoin de ce tourisme et puis on
salue le travail du comité martiniquais
du tourisme et dossier ambassadeurs
comme toi un peu partout dans le monde
qui ramène justement des gens pour
découvrir notre belle culture merci mme
vie de labeur et à très bientôt
merci et merci
de votre fidélité et de nous suivre on
se retrouve très vite si en martinique
la première
[Musique]